was there somebody who you wanted on the
remix to throw a baby that you that you
didn't get on the remix or maybe it
didn't come together in time
um
oh yeah yeah cardi oh cardi b oh my god
she came back it came back too late that
would have been
crazy i ain't been too late did she like
record the verse
i don't think she got to the verse but
by the time it was already
it was already locked and said so cardi
b was
but wanted to get on the remix i don't
know she wanted to i reached out i had
reached out to but it was looking like
it was a possibility it just didn't
happen it was definitely a possibility
that would have been a perfect fit man
yeah yeah but you know it kind of came
together better than what he did
i feel like you now have a song that's
like up there with like akanellis put it
in your mouth
as far as like best like songs about
giving head ever there's shauna getting
some head yep
there's noriega eight head which is on
the nre album
uh you know and now their throat baby
yeah
feels good it's in a it's in a it's a
whole new world
at times or because like sometimes
you don't want to [ __ ] you just want to
get ahead you don't want it
it's all but see in my in my situation
it was a little different though
because i didn't really like head like
that you didn't like head like that uh
who did what was it first of all that's
what's going on there
i mean it just went they went talking
about nah you just didn't have the right
broad huh see it wasn't even there it's
like with me
like i'm the type of person that like i
got to feel some type of way about you
to even like be stimulated
so it was just a lot of stuff that would
just spur at the moment like okay we
finna do this and then get it out the
way
just me looking down it was just like no
i don't like her
but for when to look down and then it it
it made me feel some type of way i'm
like okay i'm stimulating
you know i'm saying she made me feel
this this what i've been missing
and i had to make a song about what i've
been missing